hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel if you've been following me
for a while or you need me from IGN or
my games media days before that then you
probably know that I'm an enormous fan
of the Gears of War franchise I really
love kids
and I had the absolute pleasure of
recording some voice lines for Gears 5
so I am in this game I'm in the credits
I am officially in one of the games in
this franchise and that is crazy cool
and so I finally got to a point in Gears
5 where I think that two of my
characters are sitting around somewhere
so I wanted to capture the moments of me
finding them for the first time people
have semi clips and photos of them
fighting it but I've been late to
playing this game because stand there
are a lot of video games out right now
so I have heard it but I haven't really
experienced it for myself
I've actually been pretty chill about
this whole thing and now that I booted
it up and I'm actually doing it and I
know that one of my characters is nearby
it's a whole other thing
this is crazy I've been playing games
for a decade if I could tell thirteen
year old Alana who wanted an Xbox 360
because one of her friends played Gears
of War and she was obsessed with it that
at some point in the future I would be
in one of these games ok let me just
start looking because there's no reason
I can't talk and look at the same time I
also have no idea where about
specifically I am in this area I just
know that I'm in this camp somewhere I
think one of my characters is that root
for the record and this game is pretty
so a lot of people ask me how this
happened and what games I've been voice
acting for etc etc I am in I've recorded
for three games so far I'm also in a
game called off the potty
there you going dog where are you going
all right bye after parties coming out
late this year and I am most significant
characters and off the body whereas in
this game I'm really just NPCs who help
populate this town
whereas in off the potty I'm more of a
quest giver of a third game I'm not
allowed to tell you about yet so it'll
be something something I'm very new to
that I would like to learn how to get
better at that I'm by no means an expert
at so for all the people who've been
like oh be really cool he would make a
like how to voice act video I'm totally
not at a place where I can do that just
yet I have a small amount of experience
with studios that have been very patient
with me and very helpful with me I think
I recorded for maybe like seven
characters in Gears 5 I know of three
that made it and one of them only like a
couple of people have picked up on
because I am doing a voice like a
different accent it's not just me
speaking so that one's a lot less
obvious but Jia's came about literally
because Rod Fergusson asked me about a
year in a hospital he asked if I was
willing to be a part of the game and
naturally as an enormous Gears of War
fan I said yes and it's something that
I've had a lot of fun doing I really
really liked doing it I don't think that
I would be interested in voice acting
for anything other than video games cuz
video games are my passion of course I
don't know that it's something I'd want
to try to branch into doing but cartoons
or whatever else TVs are the reason my
old man left the COG back in the day
didn't trust him that's me yeah well
we'll see how poetic er just you find
out when I punch the Beach DB start
marching through town
their problems are our problems what you
want to join them I don't like that line
no doesn't like that one who seen
stranger bedfellows in a tough fight
what if it's all sigh ups tricks ever
think of that huh some plan to get us
back on the bad side so this is the one
where I was like a conspiracy theorist
hang on you're suggesting the COG wants
its entire army turned against it just
to convince us to rejoin the coalition
that's your informed view yeah that is
with adjustments mind you you don't
think it's possible no I don't why not
look conspiracies are about controlling
the outcome losing your army on purpose
isn't a great way to maintain control
maybe the call is controlling to you
right now controlling me
oh so weird it's so weird oh man so that
one specifically with everything that I
recorded figures of war they make you
record three versions of every line so
three versions of every sentence so you
do them all differently and then they
get to pick which one they like the most
that one specifically I didn't have a
character to respond to so the people on
the other side of the booth the
directors were reading my lines
oh sorry reading the other characters
lines so I was responding to them in a
conversational way rather than
responding to the actor but sometimes
they actually cue the actor in so they
play them through your headphones and
then you respond to them like a
conversation which is actually really
cool I liked doing it that way
[Music]
very weird obviously does it look like
me and she didn't seem to be moving at
all that's
yeah very cool okay I know there's
another one around here somewhere
got what I was saying before I rudely
interrupted myself okay try as I might
just went through a big old combat
section cleared this place the hell out
I could only find one of them I think
the other one I must have missed because
I feel like it happens from what I've
seen from what people have showed me
before
there's combat it seems like the village
is still peaceful
well maybe happens later in the game
when you go back to that point I'm not
sure all right
Oscar okay give me a second all right
I'm talking with people on the internet
all right and then the other one I think
I'm in a comms tower but this was very
cool it's a very cool thing to be able
to do a genuine honor to have been able
to do it even if I am just some minor
background NPCs and again I just keep
thinking that 13 year old Alana I don't
think I'd believe it if you told me that
at the time that I would be in eight
years of war game when that is a
franchise that I have just loved so much
my whole life pretty much at least half
of it I actually had a girl I went to
high school with message me and
congratulate me on being in the game
because she came over one night just not
to he has to came out her boyfriend of
broken up with her so I was talking to
this girl about her breakup while
playing through that entire campaign and
I remember that so vividly just a lot of
really awesome experiences out of this
franchise now I'm in it and that's very
cool so yeah again sorry that I can't
answer your questions about voice acting
more helpfully if I feel like I'm in a
place where I'm confident and I'm not
just like doing cameos and taking every
opportunity I can to learn then I'm sure
that I would but right now I feel like
it would be arrogant of me to give any
everyone or anyone advice I am
definitely not that yet
but I do have plans to continue doing it
don't have points do it full-time or
anything but I don't want to stop doing
it
it had a lot of fun and I really do love
videogames it's also just really cool
that this is the first game when my
name's in the credits and again that
it's gives afore is a huge deal so of
course I will announce more voice
projects when I can off to potty I'm
really excited about those ones I did a
British accent for one of them hopefully
it's authentic but thank you all for
watching I will see you guys next time
okay